let's start today with the most exciting
titillating and electrifying topic for
my audience tax policy of course many of
you sent me a clip that we're going to
look at of Senator Bernie Sanders from
Vermont being interviewed by now CNN's
Chris Wallace formerly of Fox News in
this clip Bernie Sanders effectively
says confiscate all income above
999 million dollars per year how many
people in the United States does this
even apply to it's very few I'll tell
you roughly the number in a moment but
what we're talking about here is a 100
percent
effective tax rate on income at a
billion dollars a year or more
but don't take my word for it here's
Bernie explaining it himself sir you're
saying sir billionaire should not exist
so are you basically saying that once
you get to 999 million dollars that the
government should confiscate all the
rest I'm saying that we should go back
to a very progressive tax policy like
what we had under Dwight D ISO which
would mean that that over a billion
dollars basically it all goes to the
government you may disagree with me
fine yeah I think people can make it on
900 you know 99 million dollars now
there is some
it's not even debate it's sort of a lack
of clarity is Bernie talking about a 100
marginal tax rate on all income at a
billion or more per year or is Bernie
talking about a wealth tax
such that you are always brought back
down to a net worth of a billion dollars
it's not completely clear but because he
says the times of Dwight D Eisenhower
tax policy under Eisenhower was a very
very high marginal tax rate on income so
for the sake of today's discussion let's
assume Bernie is talking about income
taxes rather than a wealth tax so the
first question is has this ever been
done before the answer is no there is no
historical precedent for a 100 percent
marginal tax rate essentially
confiscating all income above a certain
threshold there are governments that
have put in place very high tax rates on
the wealthy at high levels that
effectively is close to a 100 percent
tax at an extremely high level but we
never had 100 percent now just because
you haven't done something doesn't mean
it's a bad idea it's just that it hasn't
been done so we don't have something to
to look to but that's what really we're
talking talking about here for the sake
of argument a 100 percent tax bracket
that starts at a billion dollars on your
first 10 I forget exactly where the tax
brackets are right now but on your first
10 grand everybody pays zero federally
of course and then on that next bit you
take pay ten percent fifteen percent you
get all the way up to thirty five thirty
seven percent
um at about half a million bucks and
then at a billion dollars it's a 100
percent tax rate the highest it ever got
in the US as Bernie mentions is under
Eisenhower in the mid uh 20th century
with a roughly 90 percent marginal tax
bracket but again that's on income above
a certain threshold there are European
countries with very high tax rates on
the wealthy but it's not 100 now what I
want to talk we're not going to have a
100 tax rate anytime soon so what I
think is more use useful to talk about
is how can we achieve the goal that
Bernie is espousing and the goal here is
to actually collect more in taxes from
the very very very rich and as we know
there are complex season complexities
and difficulties to actually enforcing
this sort of thing for all of the
different reasons that we've talked
about and I will talk to you again now
the question of how many people this
applies to is an interesting one
um in 2022
the Forbes billionaire list said there
were 724 billionaires in the U.S I
believe now it's gone up a little bit to
like 735 billionaires in the U.S they
don't all earn a billion a year but some
of them do so we're talking about a
policy that would apply to a fraction of
the 700 something billionaires in the
United States now one of the first
issues as I know many of you know is
that many of these billionaires don't
actually earn income they receive
dividends and are subject to capital
gains so then it's well it's not just
about income over 999 billion it's other
forms of of proceeds as well that are
not actually subject to income tax rates
the point here is what are the
mechanisms through which we might
achieve a goal that is quite frankly
quite popular among the American people
when you survey the American people and
you say
should taxation be used
to collect more money from the very rich
in order to fund social programs It's
relatively uncontroversial most
Americans say yes you should now I do a
deep dive into this in my clip called
how to actually tax the rich there is no
one policy that would cover all
situations but some of the things that
could or should be looked at is okay
raise the top marginal income tax rate
that will cover
income the earned income but many of
these folks don't earn wages and they're
able to reduce actual taxation in a lot
of different ways including by receiving
income in other ways so then you could
look at well we could impose a wealth
tax the problem with the wealth tax
would be that these folks would move
assets to countries with no wealth tax
or invest in assets that are difficult
to Value like artwork or rare
Collectibles okay but again remember
it's like with gun violence no one
policy
would cover every situation but the idea
is to get some of the low-hanging fruit
you can close tax loopholes like the
carried interest loophole the counter to
that is you can move assets offshore you
can change business structure you can
Lobby for a different loophole you can
shift Investments to tax-exempt assets
like municipal bonds and it's not
realistic for most hedge funds certainly
but
um that's another possibility you can
better fund the IRS to do more audits
some of the people that we're talking
about are doing everything legally
incorrectly and paying every dollar that
they should be paying in taxes so audits
wouldn't recover any money from them but
there are some that um that that are not
and so uh increasing IRS resources is an
idea a financial transaction tax with
the ultra wealthy engaging in certain
types of transactions that average
income people do not engage in a
financial transaction tax is a
possibility of course the way to avoid
that would be
um weight just wait move assets to
countries that don't have such attacks
Etc you could require country by country
income reporting for companies one of
the ways that companies can avoid uh
corporate taxes now we're talking about
companies rather than individuals is
Shifting income to other countries that
is no longer subject to American
taxation you could pass a law that says
no that has to be reported and there has
to be some kind of corporate minimum tax
that is paid you can also look at
raising the tax rate on capital gains
and so that would get around this issue
of a lot of these very rich folks aren't
earning income subject to income taxes
so you can raise the tax on capital
gains the way around that would be you
just wait to realize the gains or look
at other mechanisms and you can also
expand the Alternative Minimum Tax we
already know that with a minimum tax
High earners can still reduce their
taxable income through deductions tax
credits and other strategies but
increasing that minimum tax is another
approach so those are ideas to achieve
what is the underlying principle that
Bernie is espousing here I don't expect
a hundred percent tax bracket anytime
soon in the United States I never say
never but certainly not in at least the
next five years one of our sponsors is
Helix sleep I have been sleeping on a
helix mattress at home for years now I
couldn't be more happy with it I
recommend it to everybody the other day
even though she's not allowed in the big
bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you are supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 off plus two free
pillows what other mattress company is
going to give you 20 off go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is down
below